hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to stranded deep a game
where you play
underwater and that is exactly all that
i know about it
so let's get to it this is actually a
pretty highly rated game on steam and it
came out just recently
so i'm going to give it a go i don't
know if it's more inclined to be
i'm sorry oh i'm on a plane this isn't
underwater at all
i was light what find a serving trolley
and make yourself a martini
priorities everybody of course i did not
know that i was without a martini
on my private jet of course this
actually reminds me a lot of the forest
it actually looks quite nice hello
pilots how are you
craftable objects are hold in orange
i didn't read that at all correctly hold
after crafting marti
yes only the finest of course
excuse my spit everybody uh tab to
select my light
oh do i need to light my cigar wait what
why do i need to use the lighter on the
martini oh it's a flaming martini
i'm gonna drink this liquid fire
everybody hope you don't mind
i'm a complete badass and slightly
crazy
all right then okay whoa hey wait a
minute i can't go back
oh do i need another martini
oh me thinks that water approaches
rapidly can i get back to my seat now
thank you yes
please i have work to do making me more
money i'm about to find a an infinite
money machine that's eventually going to
use cat fur as a point of sale oh no
no holy hell
all righty then any minute now
god this is a lot like the forest and
castaway for some strange reason
except that i'm not a low fedex employee
i'm
actually a very high oh
society person
well we're underwater now do i need to i
need to survive
uh i need to get to a life raft on the
surface oh i need to dive down
up all righty then this is terrifying
god like
one of my worst fears is like not only
just being
out in the open ocean but like being on
the open ocean
while you're being sucked down into the
depths
by a falling plane my god that would be
so terrible hello
that's gonna suck me in i saw the first
episode of lost you can't fool me
excuse my spit linear
flinier flying air fly near
okay so what do i do
i'm not under water at all am i done
what do i do oh why am i okay i'm not oh
no
what is going on
that was one hell of an intro man oh
it's totally castaway i'm going for it i
guess
uh uh we're alrighty then i'm out in the
middle of the ocean this isn't what i
wanted at all
okay then i best hurry ah sharks are
about to eat my butt
ah okay maybe i'm okay i think i might
be okay
i'm okay wow that's so cool oh that's so
cool
did i mention how cool it was no it's
really cool
oh my god this this does remind me
heavily of the forest
except i'm actually on an island but i
think i see other islands in the
distance
which makes me assume oh item i don't
mind i met him i saw item
can't fool me i don't know what i saw
don't tell me i didn't okay never mind
then
so i see other islands in the distance
which only can lead me to believe that i
can get to them
in case they have more resources than i
have here
so what do i do i probably shouldn't
have left my o
me put rock and stick together me make
axe
me make good axe how do i is there any
way i
wha i just need to shake off oh i need
to look at my watch okay
all right wow that's crazy my watch
comes with a daze survived function
that's so convenient i they called me
crazy when i got a watch with that
function but
i knew better i knew my luck in high
society wouldn't run forever
also my shadow appears to just be things
floating
okay i appear to be just floating i have
no shadow
all right so i have a rock how do i
how do i do okay there we are then
all um then i guess i need to survive
which probably isn't going to happen
knowing me
i'm not going to do anything right so
there was no way to like
okay pick up a stick okay it taught me
how to craft
but i can't appear to actually do
anything just yet
okay i got another stick so what am i
supposed to do with six
what did what did uh what did tom hanks
do let me just try to think back and
remember what the hell he did
i have no goddamn idea i'm gonna die
i need to panic first i gotta get all my
panicking out of my system
i'm gonna die oh oh my family
ah everyone i knew in love thinks i'm
dead i'm gonna be stuck here forever
where's wilson ah okay now that i got
all that out of my system
i should be fine just ah oh god
everything is horrible i'm gonna die
okay
i think i'm good i think i've got it all
out now i can calmly and rationally try
to approach this
no i'm good i'm good i'm all set so i i
probably shouldn't have left my raft but
i didn't know how to pilot it over here
so there's a crafting system involved i
have to get enough stuff to be able to
do
something ah there we go i forgot i had
a backpack okay
so i've got sticks so what do i do with
my
sticks and how do i put a rock
okay i guess just like that so i can
collect stuff
i'm not dumb i can definitely click
could break into something useful like
what
okay so i got my knife i'm gonna try to
try to hack away at stuff
nope that's a no-no that's a negative
that's no
absolutely not i am stuck that tree's
not even in the ground
ah i think i am boned but i won't give
up yet
because apparently there's we a potato
plant
what what that's not how potatoes work
i won't complain i got potatoes hey this
kept that guy alive on the martian
or in the marsh in the book yeah
give me your delicious crab meat yes i
got you now
okay so i probably can it's just a tiny
baby crab over there
death to you oh that was mean but i felt
good about it
no i don't i feel bad i'm stuck alone i
gotta survive
hey don't judge me i that's an odd
request to say to body audience but
don't
judge me i'm trying my best okay so i
got crab
okay then oddly enough oh
crabs are just like apples am i vomiting
i'm probably food poisoned um god i i
i know it was like right click and it
was able to craft something but it's not
letting me do that
so i got to be able to well how do i
craft
okay there's got to be something here
that i'm missing because i know
that when i right clicked it was like
right click on the thing it'll open up a
menu you'll be able to craft but it was
only when they were on the ground
or it was only when they were in the
environment what am i missing what am i
missing
what the hell am i missing this is going
to take a while let me fast forward to
the point where i actually know what i'm
doing
oh that's a shark holy hell that's a
shark
ugh i don't want to go near him i mean
oh that is another shark hello are you
my friend
hey buddy you can't get me up here right
god you are terrifying
and don't get me
huh look out the music
you can't get me ah
it's so scary hey what you gonna do
ah no no no i got a knife i'll knife you
knife you're right in the gamba
did i get you i poke your tail a little
bit yeah you better run
oh yeah you better not come into my area
or else i'm really going to give you
what for wow
you're scary you're not even a great
white you're just a tiger shark yeah
that's right
guy here you ain't no tiger get lost
oh here we go okay all right i got i got
a six aren't weren't gonna do it i need
to get wood
that's not a joke whatever shut up i got
it
okay i didn't know that a knife was
gonna be able to do this whoo
and coconuts i got a bunch of cocoa nuts
okay so i i think i need to chop this up
into segments
because i or my inventory's full
actually so i need to drop some stuff
so i can no i need to chop it okay
all right didn't want to drink that but
okay whatever yeah
there we go i got it i got a log what do
i do with a log
do i do any more with a log
what do i do
hey i broke it into six god damn that
sexy
that's not what i wanted to do at all
i'm such an idiot okay i need the log
not the trunk
ah just bear with me everybody i'm gonna
fast forward to the point where i get
something to show you
and just bear with me all right okay
what are you
yes yes okay this is what happened this
is what i thought was happening because
the game is very in the physical sense
so everything has to be there
to be able to make something like i'm
not wrong i'm not crazy
yes exactly god yes absolutely
that's what i needed uh poop i don't
have enough what do i what do i not have
enough of rocks i got rocks
yeah there we go okay yes absolutely i
need a crude axe and a crude hammer
so that i can be able to have these
tools give me give me and
no not that don't give me that i don't
want that give me that
yes i am caveman
i am make tool i make good on this world
so now that i have a crude axe i can
build more so i need more lashing
is what it is a rope rather rope lashing
whatever you want to call it looks like
rope to me to be perfectly honest but
not really
so that's what i need give me give me
give me give me gear i don't have enough
room
uh uh i'm just gonna put all of my
shears
in one pile why did i not notice those
plants before
like it was really obvious i guess not
really obvious but you know what i meant
i'm i'm i should have noticed that but i
didn't
because i'm a doof all right give me
where'd you go where'd you go
there you are give me give me uh i want
more of you
one more god i i should have just tried
to collect everything on the island
first because i wasted a lot of time
give me give me give me give me i think
you think you okay so i need to be able
to build
something uh wait
a crude building tool with poor
durability required for building
crude cutting tool useful for chopping
trees okay
so if i put the rest of my rope
here on the pile that would be able to
make
a bed holy crap
that's awesome and then oh oh
i can sleep by the moonlight oh it's
beautiful i don't even have to worry
about the sharks
i thought that this was all going to
take place underwater
but i'm totally fine that's amazing
this is so cool no that seriously this
game is really cool
and pretty too god i really really like
this
this is a lot of fun like the forest had
a lot of limitations
on what it could be but then again it
was just like
that's what it was so maybe i can crack
open these
yeah there we go yeah there we go
kimmy drinkable give me give me all
right whatever god
get these out of here that one
drink away yeah i got some fresh water
in me
i don't know how much i'm gonna need but
hey it is what it is
can i make it an eatable coconut can i
make an eatable cocoa nut
there we go coconut half give me that
i'm gonna eat it up
black i guess black
okay i did what i did came to do what i
came to do and i'm good
okay so now it's just survival at this
point i probably gotta get a lot more
logs to be perfectly honest
i haven't used the one i had i don't
think there's gonna be enough here but i
need a lot more lashing that's the first
thing
oh god this is so cool i'm not a total
idiot
which is a first for me like usually i'm
totally lost i'm like
oh please comment tell me what to do but
now i'm actually doing it which is
like you guys may not be all that proud
of me but i hope you are
and i'm really doing it hey hey
all right cool thank you thank you thank
you okay um
uh where do i go from here i don't know
what i need to do besides get more rope
like that's
mission priority number one well there's
more potatoes
not that i needed more potatoes um see i
need i have three lashing
i need more of those yucca plants
because if i can get more of the yuca
plants i should have enough to be able
to build some kind of like
a raft or something that way i can get
to the other plants or the other islands
safely so i imagine there's got to be a
lot of other stuff on the other islands
given that this is like the
quote-unquote starting island
this is going to hurt me eating raw
potato i just still don't know why
potatoes growing on an island all alone
but
hey it is what it is and i gotta do what
i gotta do so let me just get all my
lashing over in one
spot along with my logs
okay not enough need more need more uh
let me go ahead and chop down another
tree because i don't know if that's
gonna be necessary
yes apparently when you chop down a tree
it just goes
up by a centimeter each hit until it
just falls over from separation
okay then give give give this is gonna
take a while give
give give give give give give
give
oh wait that was already a log
okay what about that whoa
no not enough can we try
hey oh oh really oh that's all i needed
oh okay
i thought it was gonna be a bit more
complicated than that uh
yeah that's good okay that's good so i
need more palm fronds
and rope i'm guessing because i need to
make some sort of like a
roof or something like that i'm not sure
but either way
i think i know what i'm doing i got a
mission everybody i got a mission
no no no no no no no no no not in the
water
not in the scary water
okay i don't think there are any sharks
nearby i should be fine
hopefully okay what can i do with this
all right ah
so the majority of it was just gonna be
made out of sticks anyway
ah crazy that's so crazy
that's so cool okay so
i can make a wall i just put the wall
right
uh okay apparently not
what what come on
it's on the foundation i think anyway
maybe i had to make foundation supports
all right at least it's forgiving okay
uh support
yeah okay that's what's first okay so i
gotta do that first
stick give give give come on do it there
we go blammo
ah come on come on
yeah buddy yeah baby there we go
all right okay all right
i'm really excited i'm actually doing it
i can't believe it
yes yeah i need to expand this i i need
to make more uh can i make a foundation
still
damn it okay i need more sticks that's
what i need right now i got it
i'm gonna build a home i'm gonna build a
real-life home
so then somehow i need to make a raft
but i think i need to make that out of
logs
i need to know more about this game in
the first place because i'm doing all
this
through just me figuring out what to do
i need to be able to look up stuff and
get recipes going because
if i don't i'm probably gonna be dead
just saying probably not maybe but
probably
definitely dead i'm gonna die basically
this is a matter of time at this point
before i end this episode i want to get
eaten by a shark oh
it's raining oh i didn't know that
weather was a part of this game
i need to find some shelter but i'm
almost done i'm almost done guys i can
show you what i got going on
i'm super duper excited god i'm still
spitting profusely
oh man you guys are going to be so proud
of me oh you're going to be so proud of
me
ah hell no it's raining i need to get to
shelter
which i have
okay hang on wait one second i just got
to spit all this rest out um
build need another
whoa right wait
do i need another hole yeah i need
another wall right here
yes yeah i have a cabana
oh i did it i did it everybody whoa
i did it i'm so excited okay all right
this game
is awesome i love this game i barely
scratched the surface of what can be
done i know there's gotta be a ton of
more craftables that are out there
and uh i'm gonna save my game real quick
because i haven't done that yet
but i want to be eaten by a shark i want
that to happen before
i want that to be the crowning
achievement of this playthrough
go into the scary dark bla is that a
shark
is that a shark is that a fish okay i'm
gonna go out into the inky dark water
oh this is terrifying is that a shark
oh it's a shark isn't it is that a shark
is that a shark or is that just a
reflection that's a shark isn't it is
that a shark
that's a shark okay i'm just swimming
out
just out all by my lonesome in the
terrifying black abyss
shark hey oh okay i can go underwater
then
okay no no no no this isn't terrifying
at all
no this isn't the scariest thing i've
ever done god
you would never ever ever catch me doing
this
in real life in any oh oh i can't see
the bottom
oh oh i fear for my life
shark shark
don't drown now wouldn't want to drown i
think that's my home i'm leaving
shark wait which one was my home
oh they're the same thing i'm spinning
around in a circle
oh god damn it sardine really hey you
gonna come creeping up on me like that i
just want to go back home
want to go back to my home my cabana
oh finally the rain stopped maybe i can
actually
spot a shark now maybe i can actually
swim to another place
maybe my raft is still out there but i'm
just too scared to go
face it oh i found a shark i guess they
don't come out there in the oh
oh oh
hi how are you doing you're a pretty one
ain't you
oh you ain't gonna bother nobody do you
want to be my friend
do you want to be shiny shark charles
charger god you're terrifying
oh man come back here i'm gonna i'm
gonna eat you
i'm gonna get you yeah yeah
oh that music don't sound too good but
i'm gonna get this shark
yeah i'm king of the shark you ain't
gonna eat me
maybe that's right yeah you better run
okay i don't i don't seem to be doing
too good but
all right then i think i won
oh i just killed it i feel bad now
i'm just gonna drag this shark on land
i'm doing so good at this game
why am i doing so good at this game i
i won a shark i i literally won a shark
like a prize
what the hell wha what whoa whoa
okay found a bug found a bug found a bug
found a bug
i found the bug i found okay
oh okay
i think i won the game okay
what the hell so either way my voice is
almost gone i've been like
so excited to play this game but also
i've been i had a little bit of a sore
throat earlier so it kind of
kind of strained it a little bit but
either way i'm gonna do fine
thank you all so much for watching let
me know what you think of this game in
the comments below
and let me know what i should do in the
next one i'm actually going to read
unlike the escapists i won't be at pax
so i'll be able to read what you guys
tell me
so let me know what you guys think i
should do i will play it again
i will win again and i might find
another bug again so thanks again
everybody for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye stop at me stop at gorilla
version of me
stop humping that bus
it's a very detailed scenario bring it
home so so in this lake house in upstate
new york
in fat skills